Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Cucina Buttata, oggi faremo
le Big Bubble - Non ci credo che fai le Big Bubble (Gianmarco) - Ma dove sei stato quindi quando
ma come? Bravo però mi
piace questo tipo di reazione da parte
del nostro pubblico. In realtà è
piuttosto semplice fare queste gomme da
masticare. La cosa difficile è trovare gli
ingredienti, infatti per me è stato un
pochino tosto tanto che alla fine ho
dovuto ordinare un kit online pur di
riuscire a ottenere questa roba qui. Sono
impazzito! Partiamo subito con gli
ingredienti. Per fare le Big Babol avrete
bisogno di: gomma base, zucchero a velo
sciroppo di glucosio, ed è bellissimo non so
se lo vedete. Non puoi farlo tu. Questa
roba che può essere male interpretata in
realtà sono aroma di ciliegia o aroma
di uva. Le big bubble hanno un'aroma di
fragola ma io adoro l'aroma d'uva, quindi
dopo ce li assaggiamo e capiamo che
mix fare. Vabbè non stiamo facendo
praticamente le Big Bubble. E infine
colorante alimentare rosa, proprio come
quello delle Big Bubble
- Cioè voi fate la gomma scigliendo la gomma e risolidificandola? (Roberta) - Si. Io posso a
bagnomaria far andare questa roba qua
dentro, che resiste, ma la domanda è come
faccio a chiuderlo?! La pellicola "in frigo o nel microonde"
Vogliamo provare a vedere che succede?
Che resistenza ha? "Non utilizzabile a
temperature superiori ai 150 gradi per
più di 30 minuti". Quindi va alla grande
Mettiamo la gomma a galleggiare e nel
frattempo cerchiamo di ammorbidire
questo cosino qui. Questo
cosino qui si ammorbidisce sempre
mettendolo un pochino in acqua calda, dai!
Adesso sta diventando molto più morbido
fidati - Vai! Schiaccialo col...fa vedere
- Sembran droga. Regà, sembra che
stiamo facendo una puntata di Gomorra
Sa di un odore...hai presente...questo è...
- Ciliegia - Regà ma già solo questo sa di Big Bubble - Ciliegia ve? Oh ragazzi non ho...
- Il grembiule! Il grembiule!
Walter White (Gianmarco) - Quindi
fondamentalmente quello che dobbiamo fare è
aspettare che si sciolga la gomma, unirla
al nostro glucosio che stiamo facendo
ammorbidire...Uh - Per avere una purezza al 99 per 100 (Enrico)
- Ok qui si sta pian piano
sciogliendo. Più che altro vedi quanto è
gonfio? E' inutile che fingiamo, sto
facendo queste! Ingredienti naturali
A me non mi da l'idea che questo sia naturale, mi
sembra tutto finto
♫ Non c'è niente al mondo che vorrei di più di te, io più di
tutto quel che adesso... fra di noi
Perché io non ti cambierei nemmeno per, nemmeno per
un milione ♫ - A proposito di milione ragazzi
ci siamo quasi eh, ed è
meravigliosa questa cosa. Bisogna anche...
le persone ringraziano quando
vanno le cose capito? "Grazie". Bisogna
ringraziare in generale per questo
enorme crescita di quest'ultimo periodo
Sono veramente contento, grazie mille! - Bravo! (Enrico) - Ho fatto bene vero? - Sisi (Enrico)
- Ho fatto capire di essere comunque una persona del popolo?! - Anche se dopo questo video tornerai
alla tua povertà (Enrico) - ... - Sono un po' confuso
posso dirlo? - Anche se non lo dici si capisce (Enrico) - E' perché sono, ho una grandissima espressività lo so
- Fondamentalmente quando noi mangiamo una gomma
in realtà noi consumiamo un sacco di
prodotti pieni di zucchero. Io mi sento
potente con questa tra le mani quando
parlo e dico delle cose sagge
♫ Voglio parlare
al tuo cuore, voglio vivere per me di
sole e d'azzurro ♫ - Ma non è da copyright? (Enrico) - Era molto simile all'originale, quindi
bisogna stare molto attenti è vero! - Si sta sciogliendo? (Enrico) - Si lentamente, molto lentamente ma si scioglie
♫ Love lips us up where we belong ♫
Anche questa - Neanche la posso montare infatti (Enrico) - Era Muolin Rouge (Gianmarco) - Si
- Vabbè già quelli rubavano le
canzoni già fatte (Gianmarco) - Beh non funziona
proprio così - Rubavano ahaha! (Enrico)
Si sono tutte cover - ♫ Aleluia
Aleluuuuuuuuuia ♫
- Questa è quella di Shrek (Enrico)- Che è una cover
- Devo dire che l'orco l'hai fatto...(Enrico) - Molto bene
- Vai ve ne faccio un'altra - ♫ Ora vieni con me, verso
un mondo di incanto, principessa è tanto
che il tuo cuore aspetta un si. Aprì gli
occhi e vedrai, tra mille diamanti ♫
- Anche lo straccione ti riesce bene (Enrico)
♫ Non sono uno straccione, solo un poveraccio ♫            - Forse è droga veramente (Gianmarco)
Si sta sciogliendo. Dai dammi un tema - Soitudine (Enrico)
♫ Marco se n'è andato e non ritorna più. Non è possibile
Il signore sta nel suo santo tempio ♫
- Proviamo tipo, non lo so, un trio. Devi fare Simba (Gianamrco - Tu sei Timon e quello è Pumba
♫ Io l'ho già capito (G) - Cosa? (E) - Ma loro ancora no (G) - Chi?
Si stanno innamorando e il nostro trio...
diventerà un duo ♫ - ... - Ma che è curry? - Beh si è un po' brutto da vedere (E) - Mo ci devo aggiungere
questo...Allora lo mischio col dito. Non brucia nemmeno
così tanto
- Scena orripilante (G) - Mamma mia davvero! (E)               - Sembra Voldemort appena
esce a Harry Potter 4 (G)
- Questo qui si fa in due secondi se la tiri. Ancora non ho usato il colorante
- Bravo, in realtà quando lo dovresti usare? (E) - Ah boh, non c'è nemmeno una ricetta
Dovremmo aggiungere il sapore. Quale dei due? - Quello meno sgravato (G)
Tutto questo? Stai facendo un raviolo (E)
- Quella cosa la dobbiamo anche masticare dopo? (Roberta) - Certo
♫ dialetto napoletano ♫
- Facci qualcosa invece di... (E)
- Arrabbiato? - Di arrabbiato (E)
♫ Oh oh oh oh
Roberta tu sei esperta, del mio cuore
esperta d'amore ♫ - Guarda questa è una hit! (E)
♫ Tu studi architettura, non è mica
cultura...e metto zucchero a velo, voglio
togliere il velo dai tuoi occhi, perché
poi alla fine tu mi sbrocchi ♫
- Ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine
Lo sai che non è male (E) - Mi ispira (G) - ♫ La prima volta che t'ho vista
non volevi che ti parlassi,
adesso che vinco se solo poker di assi ♫
♫ Mangiati una gomma, non mi parlare adesso
se vuoi parlar con me, facciamo solo sesso ♫
♫ Vengo dalla strada e lì sono rimasto
perché non ho fatto una lira ♫
Sto già migliorando Neo di Matrix - Ma poi se le incarti? (E)
Che voglia di fare! - Ci sta questa maglietta che ti fa enorme (E) - Grasso?
- No no, cioè, esatto - E' il grembiule (G) - Ah il grembiule dici? (E)
- Certo sembra che ha quel vitino e quelle spalle (G)              - Basta giudicare le persone dal loro aspetto, ciccione!
Ragazzi - ... - Mazza! (E) - Roby, tu che hai tanto criticato - No (Roberta) - Venite anche voi ragazzi - Io assaggio
molto volentieri (G) - Siete pronti? - Voi l'avete? - Cin cin - ... - No vabbè, diventano
pietre all'istante
- Vediamo se riusciamo a fare un palloncino
- Secondo me bisogna metterne di meno (Roberta)
- Ma forse ora è diventata commestibile - Più morbida       - Alla fine so gomme - Meglio alla fine - Sono le uniche
gomme che migliorano finendo
- Ma è la tua lingua quella? Comunque si sente...da mezz'ora. Ragazzi siamo
arrivati alla fine di questo video.
Nessuno è riuscito a fare un palloncino
- Io un po' forse - E' quello che ci si è avvicinato più di tutti
Grazie per aver... - Finale disgustoso - Grazie per averci seguiti. Come sempre vi chiedo se vi è piaciuto questo
video di iscrivervi, di lasciare un commento,
un pollice in su, premere la campanella
non lo so, fate qualsiasi cosa. Noi ci
vediamo la prossima domenica sempre alle
12 con un altro episodio di Cucina Buttata. Ciao
- Mo lo faccio io - Perché devi infilare la lingua
in un punto dove tutto, tutto attorno
deve essere pieno...Comincia a girarmi la testa
- Non ce la faccio...Non mi riesce - Adesso inizia ad essere una mezza m***a